we have already seen an example in which
we have two events that are independent
but become dependent in a conditional
model so that dependence and
unconditional independence is not the
same we will now see another example in
which the similar situation is obtained
the example is as follows we have two
possible coins coin a and coin B this is
the model of the world given that coin a
has been chosen so this is a conditional
model given that we have in our hands
coin a in this conditional model the
probability of heads is 0.9 and more
moreover the probability of heads is
point nine in the second toss
no matter what happened in the first
toss and so on as we continue so given a
particular coin we assume that we have
independent tosses this is another way
of saying that we are assuming
conditional independence within this
conditional model coin flips are
independent and the same assumption is
made in the other possible conditional
universe this is a universe in which we
are dealing with coin B once more we
have conditionally independent tosses
and this time the probability of heads
at each toss is point 1 suppose now that
we choose one of the two coins each coin
is chosen with the same probability 0.5
so we're equally likely to obtain this
coin and then start flipping it over and
over or that coin and start flipping it
over and over the question we will try
to answer is whether the coin tosses are
independent and by this we mean a
question that refers to the overall mode
in this general model are the different
coin tosses independent where you do not
know ahead of time which coin is going
to be we can approach this question by
trying to compare conditional and
unconditional probabilities that's what
independence is about independence is
about certain conditional probabilities
being the same as the unconditional
probabilities so this here this
comparison here is essentially the
question of whether the eleventh coin
toss is dependent or independent to from
what happens in the first ten coin
tosses let us calculate these
probabilities for this one we use the
total probability theorem there is a
certain probability that we have coin a
and then we have the probability of
heads in the eleventh toss given that it
was coin a there's also certain
probability that it's coin B and then a
conditional probability that we obtain
heads given that it was coined B we use
the numbers that are given in this
example we have point five probability
of obtaining a particular coin the point
nine probability of heads for coin a
point five probability that it's coin B
and point one probability of heads if it
is indeed coin B we do the arithmetic
and we find that the answer is zero
point five which makes perfect sense
we have coins with different biases but
the average bias is 0.5 if we do not
know which coin is going to be the
average bias is going to be 0.5 so the
probability of heads in any particular
toss is 0.5 if we do not know which coin
it is suppose now that someone told you
that the first ten tosses were heads
will this affect your beliefs about
what's going to happen in the eleventh
toss we can calculate this quantity
using the definition of conditional
probabilities or the Bayes rule but let
us instead think intuitively
if it is coined be the event of 10 heads
in a row is extremely unlikely so if I
see 10 heads in a row then I should
conclude that there is almost certainty
that I'm dealing with coin a so the
information that I'm given tells me that
I'm extremely likely to be dealing with
coin a so we might as well condition on
this equivalent information that it is
coin a that I'm dealing with but if it
is coin a then the probability of heads
is going to be equal to 0.9 so the
conditional probability is quite
different from the unconditional
probability and therefore information
the first ten tosses affects my beliefs
about what's going to happen in the 11
toss and therefore we do not have
independence between the different
tosses